Tyler
what do you think she's racing this all
right she's racing what do you think
Cheese racing I think so when I think of
cheese racing I think you take a a thing
of cheese which I imagine is a wheel
because cheese comes in wheels and
historically has been that way
um you roll it and run down the hill
with it and you have to both the cheese
and you cross the finish line
okay fascinating idea completely wrong
how silly all right close your eyes all
right you are a starving medieval
peasant I'm very hungry and oh so hungry
but you love yourself you're my Lord
English peasant he gives me a piece of
copper everyone English peasant oh
my Lord
[Music]
Papa so I can feed my family peasant
peasant I'm a poor peasant you wouldn't
speak that nice if you were a peasant
I'm a poor person to continue to spare a
cup of Peace for me
my Lord I said I said porn not diseased
I don't know
please I want food more gov oh my God
not give me the food all right
okay you
use front of you a wheel of cheese right
I steal it I'm just grabbing it and
running along hold on okay all right
that's good you said I'm starving it
yeah yeah okay you steal it and run okay
you run up there's a hill in front of
you you're running up the hill but the
sheriff is after you I got a stone a
cheese
[Music]
what part of England is he from
I'm from the poor part the part that
doesn't get food and so you run up to
this hill your name is Cooper right all
right Cooper a hill okay it's a steep
hill near glitches
and they're about to catch you but you
know the law back in front because you
aren't dumb you know I'm just poor you
know that if you are in possession of
the cheese at the time of capture then
you are liable for the crime you were
being illegal but thinking quickly
you've realized you're on a hill and if
you get the cheese a minimum of a
hundred yards away from you which is
what the law dictates and what that
cheese has to be away from you for you
not it'd be impossible to get the crime
you see an opportunity because you know
that this hill that you're on is exactly
the slope the hypotenuse of the slope is
exactly 101 yards away you see that the
sheriff is behind he's a portly fellow
he's huffing and puffing and you have
only a certain amount of time to get it
down so you thinking quickly hurl the
cheese as fast as you can down the hill
and it makes it just as a sheriff
where's that you stop right there and
you're like where I I don't know why
you're asking me to stop here because I
don't have any Chase or any possession
of stolen materials will you talk real
funny but you show me where that cheese
are all gonna slapping on
well you're gonna slap me an iron saw
you but you know what I ain't got no
cheese on me you talk smoothly with it
wait a minute how did she get all the
way to the bottom of the hill I think a
bird might have grabbed it then it
wouldn't it be up in the air well it
seems like it was a bit pretty big heavy
wheel of cheese so the bird must have
lost control of it and dropped it down
the hill you rolled that cheese didn't
you
come on look at me do I look like that
brightest fellow to be able to roll
cheese damn you got me
and that is cheese rolling
[Music]